you not a big fan of la you don't like
spending up a time there well I mean I
like her legs I've got I've got really
good friends there but it's a funny old
place this it's just a strange place and
as soon as you get there you think oh my
god my bum looks big in this this is the
Pope meeting la you know it's a problem
because I've lived there for a long time
and they say if you sit in a barbershop
for long enough you're gonna get a
haircut well if you live in Los Angeles
longer enough you're gonna get some
surgery
it's the I've had a thatch done I'll
tell everybody now I didn't even need it
know who this thing was like I had like
three months off I got bored like oh
it's okay I'll go in yeah so I got new
hair not now I've just got some rather
side going wrong on the front and the
side done and I actually didn't need it
but that's what I'm saying about Los
Angeles very like various of how
everybody looks and they also they all
know really rocky as well you know so
there's the star system thing which we
don't really have here thank goodness I
don't like that so they'll always find a
way of making you feel bad you know
there's always some VIP enclosure that
you're not eating you're naughty you
think you're in a important bit and then
you find that you're not in the most
important bit
well your ticket is green when it
actually the really important ticket is
pink they find ways of making you feel
less than or more than all the time I
don't really approve of that
that's us miss but the amount of times
I've turned up to places and the look on
people's faces they realize I'm not
Robin Williams
now I'm so used to I'm going like Robin
Williams right no sorry it's me save us
all the time
by the way can you think no no I can't
at all no but that's never stopped me if
you like to ease your pants down
his nose